a la view is the first interactive movie
about Cologne carnival Cola I laugh
laugh is something of a war-cry here the
polian was in Cologne and everything was
run in military fashion the locals
didn't like that at all so they made fun
of him at carnival time that's why they
wear uniforms in the carnival clubs but
they don't behave like soldiers quite
the opposite Erick fence is a local and
bajas ala Doc moved to Cologne ten years
ago
they complement each other as filmmakers
the HC carnival differently
yes me I'll put in my early years here I
would always go away at carnival time
not that I have had any experience of
Carnival before then Eric persuaded me
to stay and join in it was a revelation
a Lolita I was ready to say everybody
knows all the songs eventually you all
end up hugging and crying and saying how
much you love each other and singing
some more it's a bit corny and romantic
the film aims to capture the special
feel of this crazy season since carnival
began on the 11th of November the two
filmmakers have been collecting video
footage hundreds of hours worth already
people submit their material online so
far the directors have raised 20,000
euros via crowdsourcing to finance the
film it's a big experiment people send
us stuff and we have to tease a dramatic
structure out of it and the footage we
shoot ourselves we want the film to
emerge out of all the unplanned
unforeseen moments that's what it means
for a film to be user-generated
in marriage I promise to love her and
protect her till my dying breath so will
you marry me that was a real proposal it
seems lots of intimate moments and lots
of horsing around are being captured on
video across Cologne hot van hoff is a
cameraman by profession and a
contributor to Allah few 60 hours worth
for free
I am celebrating carnival for the past
15 years and it always thought about
filming it you just feel good the whole
time there's no reason not to just grin
joins in the fun during carnival and
cologne there are 2,000 people gathered
here and you have no idea who they all
are a student a lawyer a doctor I've
never asked and never been asked what do
you do for a living
dressing up and kissing strangers might
seem weird to outsiders and the local
dialect is often hard for tourists and
other Germans to understand Allah few
aims to bring alive the magic of Cologne
carnival to audiences far beyond the
Rhineland it goes on release in the
spring of next year
you